we have this from The Daily Mail I
resent it nobody watches it because it
sucks Tucker Carlson's Carlson's unloads
on Fox Nation and jokes about
post-menopausal fans in leaked videos
from his axed streaming show now what I
don't understand this is why you know
some of these videos came out yesterday
and now we've got more today and the
reason why I didn't realize I don't
really say anything is because they I
thought they were obvious deep fakes I
saw people posting his videos and I was
like ah it's funny they made a deep fake
of Tucker Carlson now I'm reading in the
news that these are serious videos and
I'm going to show you one that I think
is absolute proof these are deep fakes
so I will warn you there is swearing so
uh we if you have kids and you're
listening uh uh we have we're going to
play this video but uh take take a
listen listen to this and for those that
are watching watch the video here we go
okay I'm not you know what I'm not
qualified on that score I will say
I thought his girlfriend was kind of
yummy
just kidding just kidding cases being
pulled off the bird
yeah the bird hey Media Matters for
America go yourself that's the
first thing I want to say tonight second
thing is totally kidding I don't even
know what his girlfriend looks like and
if I did I would not find her yummy
I think that's a deep fake his eyes look
his eyes are floating like his head
moves and his eyes don't and his mouth
is like doing this weird slightly
outside thing I hope it's real but it
looks
again look at this look at his teeth
look at his upper teeth and watch this
video
and so you'll notice there's a weird
thing that happens that looks like
artifacting
also what is he even talking about
right there
there's that part right there and the
hands look fake too his eye looks a
little weird yeah look at his eyes oh
the thing with the mouth for sure the
eyes definitely look funky but here
we're going to take it a little deeper
what if they actually got recorded
footage of Tucker and then they doctored
it to make it look freaky and off so
that people would say it looks freaky
and often think it called The Conspiracy
Theory how's that or it's actually a
completely real video calling him ugly
face looks oh that's no way that's real
Tucker is saying at home like a single
tear coming down he's watching this
right now on this podcast and defend
himself then that's really the end I
mean it looks like artifacting it looks
fake I just it it I I can't when I saw
the first few videos I'm like these are
not real well I I didn't think they were
real videos I saw him on Twitter and
people were like haha this is funny and
I'm like oh that's a funny defect of
Tucker yelling at Media Matters and then
it's apparently Media Matters is
claiming it's real
company is thrilled look at his mouth
you're doing this I've gotten more calls
from people about it oh that's great
whatever I got to say
I think some of it might be real that's
what I was thinking it's like somebody
took real videos and then made deep
fakes put them together and sent it so
that Media Matters would fall for it
I completely agree sex I'd love to hit
some of the fine points of technique
wait what I've been on yours enough
times it's great
[Music]
I think it's totally cool
so let's um is if we're going to talk
about sex I'd love to hit some of the
fine points of technique
there's no way that's real see I feel
like it could be like Josh no it's
totally up to you it looks like some of
the videos look very real and they add
up and then some of them look completely
fake so like maybe like you said there's
a mixture of real videos but then
they're like oh let's see how far we can
push it I love the idea that someone's
both yeah it's it's real video with tiny
bits sliced in yeah I was I was talking
about this with Trump I said in 2024 the
Deep fakes are not gonna be overt fake
videos of trump saying something awful
it's going to be a real press conference
where they tweak one word very slightly
that way no one knows what really
happened because everyone will agree
Trump was there Trump gave a press
conference Trump trump did say he did
not like gouda cheese on his
cheeseburger but there will be like one
word tweaked the example I give is
they'll take something like when he said
I'm not talking about the white
nationalists because they should be
condemned totally and they'll change it
to some of them should be condemned
totally that way both the left and the
right agree he was there he condemned
white nationalists but then the left
will only ever see the video him saying
some of them and they'll go he's trying
to defend the uh some of them and he's
not even condemning them all and then
the right will hear him say they should
be so the context becomes different and
no one knows which one's the real one or
they're rapists right that's another
classic one but to see that was all out
of context manipulation but even that
it's like which there was he because he
kept saying they are sending there as in
people from there like their criminals
there etc etc but then when they
transcript the final there they put it
as t-h-e-y apostrophe Ari is if he was
saying they are rapists in Mexico as
opposed to Mexico is sending their
rapists over here right right right
saying right there are people there who
are rapist versus they are it's crazy
partnership versus such a small tweak
can make such a big difference
psychologically for people in the way
that they consume content like I think
deep fakes come 2024 an election season
are actually probably going to be a
pretty big problem when it comes to
misinformation oh yeah
absolutely I mean it's it's unavoidable
right well it just keeps getting better
and better and more accurate and more
realistic I will say though my favorite
like deep fakes are the you know not so
serious ones where like it has like
Trump Biden and Obama playing games yeah
and they're just like swearing at each
other one where they're talking to
Taylor Swift about yeah break up or
something I think you're right the hard
thing is people will end up having two
understandings of media right any clip
that goes viral there'll be one that
your Echo chamber of Twitter sees and
they'll be the one that I feel like it's
already like that though for the most
part like we live in a completely
alternate realities like completely
there's there's no similarities between
the left and the right anymore
regardless of how hard you look for it
and even when they are it's overshadowed
by US versus them and I think it's going
to just continue to be like that yeah I
mean there's there's a very legitimate
question of how much effect the Deep
fakes are actually going to have because
the media lies constantly anyway and
they're never held accountable for it so
this isn't exactly going to be any kind
of change of pace why would Tucker say
FU Media Matters because they suck yeah
but like
we we've talked about Media Matters but
why would he randomly while being
secretly recorded just scream this out
and then that video be sent to Media
Matters it looks like all of these
videos that are taken right before his
broadcast I think at least the ones that
look real it looks like he's probably
just like chatting with one of his
producers or something that's what I'm
thinking right but like saying a few
Media Matters is very very specific yeah
and I just kind of feel like that's
weird I don't know I feel like a lot of
people know Media Matters is not a very
trustworthy when they've attacked Claire
says that every morning
the office no I never think about Media
Matters and I know they wish I did but
the thing is like I think for Tucker or
you know any kind of office place you
have kind of one outlet that you know
doesn't like you right so being able to
say like oh I'm sorry guys like you know
that's true Media Matters does write
some great hit pieces their hit pieces
are always entertaining through and
through they're one of my favorite
companies the best is they wrote a uh
they wrote a best of list of Tim cast
IRL episodes and the best part was
Sheamus wasn't on it I wasn't on it I
was so upset and that's and so that's
what I said I said the same thing Tucker
said to Media Matters I would just say
that on air because squares are bad it's
funny because they were trying to find
any episode where someone said something
offensive and they'd find someone who
said something that was like marginally
more like just squint and turn their
head and make it bad and then here's
Sheamus who's on the show for like seven
months arguing that gay people shouldn't
be allowed to get married well not that
they shouldn't be allowed but that it's
literally not possible Gamers doesn't
exist
that's not the definition of marriage
but they did put a clip of me up in one
of their articles and the way they
labeled it was they said Tim cast host
says marriage equality is bad making it
sound like it's you and so people were
sharing the article going this is why we
can't trust these people who say they're
disaffected liberals he's uttering right
wing talking but so the guy said that
yeah
no no Jezebel did that Jezebel took one
of my greatest and it was one of my best
quotes about no fault divorce and how
horrible it is and how people would be
more selective about who they chose to
marry if that wasn't on the table and
they attributed it to Ian
not watch this show
well they're like was it like the
traditional catholic or like the new age
like hippie guy who do who do we think
said this here it's possible Ian was
saying things it's possible Ian was
saying things against divorce as well
but they literally they just
Ian was like divorce is super based and
they're like Ian Crossland said never
allow anyone to get divorced for any
reason is it the Trad Catholic or the
hippie guy yeah who do you know you want
the attention
that's why that's why in their league
Footers are like Fue in Crossland yeah
seriously I'm like no that they meant
that for me with the Tim cast list what
I remember is on Twitter everyone being
like thank you so much for this honor
Media Matters like I did appear on
timcast thank you so much like it's sort
of its own joke I mean I'm sure there
are people who trust Media Matters and
feel as though this was a true
conversation but you know it there are I
could name a handful of organizations
that like if you get a label from them
it doesn't mean anything because they
are so biased recently so recently Vice
did a kind of like semi-hit piece on me
regarding my drag coverage and said that
I lied about this and exaggerated and
said that you know a little girl was
left unattended and then now they're out
of business they're out of business
because they lied about it because they
lied about it
uh I posted that Meme on Twitter let me
pull it up yeah I just want to mention
something about this part of why they
have so much difficulty raiding oh my
gosh yeah let's look at this real quick
first actually it's super funny it's a
it's a super ripped Chiba sang It's like
Vice then I will go to the most war-torn
places on Earth to expose dirty politics
now 10 reasons why SpongeBob is
homophobic That's So based I mean but
it's like true because I worked there
and then I left and you know I was like
I was in Ukraine at the start of the
protest which eventually turned into
conflict I was in Turkey during the gesi
park riots and and the tear gas and all
that stuff I was in Egypt during the
revolution and then uh they decided that
they wanted to complain about feminist
nonsense yeah we need we need a
right-wing version of vice and not even
necessarily like a right wing we just
need a new Vice somewhere that's going
to go in these war-torn countries and
expose these things and do these drug
documentaries and all the great work
that they used to do we just need to
bring that back but with a little bit of
a Twist because they don't want to do it
anymore I feel like I was just gonna a
magic applies to all journalists
nowadays 100 yeah it's all about people
call themselves a journalists when
they're opinion columnists but
going back to what I was saying a moment
ago here in the conversation on Media
Matters and how poorly they label
conservative talking points and their
their limited understanding of where the
Overton window is with conservative
thought because they consider all of it
to be horrible part of this is a product
of the fact that the left
very poorly understands what
conservatives actually believe Jonathan
Heights research has shown this that
conservatives have a far better
understanding of what liberals believe
than liberals have of what conservatives
believe and anyone who's ever had a
conversation with someone on the left
can tell you that and so they assume
that we're all sort of at the same place
on the political Spectrum or where we
are in the political Spectrum doesn't
matter and it ends up manifesting itself
that way a few years ago there was
research done on YouTube and how it
radicalizes young people and there were
these really milk toast libertarian
organizations that got put to the right
of me I remember thinking that I know
that guy he's super libertarian he's
absolutely to the left of me why and
they put him as like far right and put
me as like a Centrist conservative what
are you talking about have you ever seen
those videos I think the cut does them
where you'll get like a group of girls
and they have to like rank themselves in
order of like attractiveness or
something and then they bring in guys
the complete opposite yeah
has any idea what the what the scale is
my favorite was when there was this
snooty woman they did this one where it
was like right IQ and this one was just
talking about how smart she was and try
she was a stupid it has all these majors
and everything and then the one person
without like any Majors ends up being
the smartest out of all of them I think
there was a study done too that
correlates like testosterone levels and
political views and as people start
working out like if liberals start
working out and their testosterone
raises and as it's a continuous raise
their ideology quite literally shifts to
more conservative and it's correlated
with testosterone that's right boot camp
every American mandatory boot camp get
that testosterone no one's got to eat a
steak that's why they want you eating
bugs and being vegan because it lowers
your testosterone it makes you frail and
dainty you want to know what's really
funny that's what you want to be by all
means Bud light's waiting for you
because because you mentioned estrogen
when my when my grandfather is Young he
thought he was going to be a priest so
he spent the ages of like 12 to 20 in a
seminary
and then he ended up fighting in the
second world war and he said basic
training in the Army was easy because of
how difficult it was in the Seminary
like that's how we used to train priests
they had to be super hardcore they would
be able to do really difficult things
yeah and now not just the priesthood but
everything that a person needs to
receive any kind of education to do is
so unbelievably watered down that we
can't expect anything of them I mean the
shows like the drag shows that I go to
that a lot of them are hosted in
churches oh my almost every single time
it is a woman who was a priest and she's
you know lesbian this lesbian that and
Episcopal not a priest yeah yeah exactly
certain certain uh Christian
denominations allow priestesses even
though there's no such thing as a
priestessood founded by Christ anywhere
in Scripture
well that's that that's what that's
Episcopalian is that the religion
episcopalians do it there's a number of
there's a number of likes I think there
was a baptism Tucker's Episcopalian
episcopalians are right we do like they
did a lot it's one of the reasons I left
the church but like Baptists allow it
the United Methodist Church in Texas are
like the Methodist churches are always
the ones with the Trans Flags they're
everywhere until and like I have friends
who grew up very liberal and they
specifically seek out Progressive
churches so having a female priest is a
way to say like hello it's us we have we
are part of the left ideology but I
think ultimately it is a a sign that
they are selling their theology to be a
part of culture well you'll hear often I
know I heard this a lot when I was going
to Anglican Episcopalian churches uh was
that you know Church attendance is down
so we have to find a way to appeal to
the young people and so you know what a
great idea is we'll put up our rainbow
flag and we'll get up we'll get a lady
priest and it's whatever the way did you
ever see the video of them the church
that like painted the rainbow everywhere
and then that one guy came by as she was
painting the room who's like what are
you doing like this is a disgrace like
you call yourself a Christian like tell
me where it says this is allowed in the
Bible yeah and she couldn't tell them
and then did you know explain that the
rainbow is God's covenant yeah you know
what's meant for the sky and not outside
your church but still you know like
you're gonna take the take the rainbow
back well I think some people came back
that's not why she was doing it yeah but
embrace the embrace the rainbow
dude look these churches that marketing
got you if you just did that I know they
got me dude I saw those commercials so
many times the scripture and you're
talking about eating I know I'm thinking
about Skittles I'm like wait a minute
it's a promise
but this happens so often where these
churches will go how do we get young
people let's be the way the world is
hold on the reason they're out in the
world and not in churches because they
want the world and not the church and if
you're just going to offer what the
world has you're not gonna you're
attracted it would be like if a
conservative organization was going you
know there's a lot of left-wing people
subscribe to these left platforms you
know maybe Tim cast needs to become more
Progressive no that's not the point
that's literally the reason people go to
timcast is because it's not offering
what most worldly press Outlets are
offering with respect to progressivism
right and the reason people go to church
is because they don't want what the
world is offering so stop trying to give
people a watered down version of it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time